but i think you need to do that with a
certain amount of intensity so that you
really get that first get to the first
ledge in your climb hi there steve
kaufman here and today i want to talk
about learning two languages at the same
time
remember if you enjoyed these videos
please subscribe uh if you're listening
uh
on a
podcast surface somewhere please leave a
review
you can click on the bell here for
notifications
so i have been learning two languages at
the same time off and on for the last
couple of years that's arabic and
persian or farsi
and i'm going i'm about to embark on
another 90-day challenge which i also
want to announce here because that link
we have these 90-day challenges where we
encourage people to commit to certain
goals
and follow up with other link members to
see how they're doing all in sort of a
bit of an effort to
you know
help each other motivate each other to
stay on our
tasks now
so i thought about what do i want to
take on as a challenge and i ended up
initially i was going to say well i'm
going to focus just on arabic and i just
i'm reluctant to leave persian even for
you know three months so i ended up
saying well i'm going to do a challenge
in both and i have indicated that at
length that i'm doing a 90-day challenge
in both arabic and persian
so i'll be doing two languages at the
same time in fact i'll be doing three
because my arabic is going to be divided
between
standard arabic which is where i have
spent most of my time and egyptian
arabic which i've just started doing
over the last few weeks here so it's
almost three languages at the same time
except that
egyptian arabic is a part of arabic as
is standard arabic
so some thoughts about this first of all
i would not recommend studying two
languages at the same time if you are a
beginner and remember i have
commented that language learning is a
bit like an upside down hockey stick so
you've got the blade of the stick which
goes up very sharply and then you have
this long shaft which sort of gradually
kind of is inclined in an upward
direction but you you're almost not
aware that you're making any progress
and so during that first steep climb
where there's a lot of initial success
all of a sudden you can say something
where you couldn't say something before
all of a sudden you understand some
things that you you know you didn't
understand anything when you started the
language was just noise at the beginning
and now there's some meaning there so
there's a great sense of achievement
it's also a period that first sort of
could be three months could be six
months depends on how difficult the
language is you have that sense that you
know the vocabulary the high frequency
vocabulary we repeat so often that you
really do feel as if you're you're
acquiring words here and and and getting
a sense of the language but then once
you've passed that whether it be after
three months or six months
because the word frequency and i've
mentioned this before the word frequency
declines so quickly you have this
impression that you're not seeing the
words often enough to really remember
them and you keep on forgetting them and
and just seems like an endless task to
build up the large passive vocabulary
that you need in order to become fluent
so
long intro to say if you're in that
first stage
the sort of uh you know
steep climb initial period i would not
recommend trying to do two languages
that's been my experience other people
have different uh you know experiences
or likes or whatever but i think you
need to do that with a certain amount of
intensity so that you really get that
first get to the first ledge in your
climb so but once you're past that first
period which is i'm past it now in both
my persian and my arabic
it's that long long road and so there i
think it is possible to to do two
languages at the same time and and i
will share with you my strategy first of
all
on the one hand because you're doing two
languages you have you know less of an
opportunity obviously to concentrate on
one
so
you will learn less quickly at least if
you had spent if i spent all my time in
arabic i would learn arabic faster
because i have done both arabic and
persian with a little bit of turkish
here that slows me down in my arabic
however
i end up with two languages instead of
one
the other thing is that at times again
because this long shaft where you you
hardly feel you're making any progress
at all
it can be
a little bit dispiriting i've called it
the doldrums which is that area of the
world where there's the wind dies and
the ships aren't moving
uh in the old days when everyone relied
on sale for for sailing
so uh
in a way sometimes you're sort of
forcing yourself to do things to learn
the language because you want to learn
the language and yet you you don't
really feel like you're making much
progress at that time i think it's kind
of good to switch from one language to
the other and back again because it's
something new something refreshing
you're
inspired again when you at least that's
been my experience when i go back to
language a after having been on language
b
so i think in that period you can cope
with two languages at the same time
another thing that i think is important
when doing two languages at the same
time or even if you're doing one
language and you're in that sort of
doldrums period the long shaft do things
that are fun
if you are sort of out of a sense of
obligation forcing yourself to
to re-read and re-review the same
material because you keep forgetting it
it can be a little bit discouraging on
the other hand
i've now found for example with my uh
with my egyptian arabic uh my tutor has
me on this um this serial on netflix
once upon a time i think it's called
it's it's it's an interesting very
interesting uh series
and so it's enjoyable i don't understand
much of it but it's enjoyable and i'm
picking up something so i do a little
bit of that i go and do a little bit of
many stories i go do a little bit of
standard arabic you know a podcast out
of al jazeera so i'm doing a certain
amount of variety but i try to do things
that i enjoy doing
similarly in persian
sahara is going to get me some movies on
youtube
she's also put in some material songs in
persian which i've been listening to and
so if i can vary the kind of material
that i'm listening to
uh things that i enjoy doing
and and therefore i'm not so fussed
about how quickly i'm improving
the improvement comes
you just have to believe that it will
come
and don't put pressure on yourself
wanting to move along more quickly if
you sort of say well i'm going to
wander
into this room my arabic room for a
while and then i'm going to go back into
my persian room
and the flavors are a little different
the colors are a little different the
content that i'm using is a little
different
so i think that's important also
i i think at this stage it's important
to have a tutor you know funnily enough
i think a tutor at the early stage is is
more difficult to take advantage of
because you can't speak you don't
understand you need to invest all that
time in listening and reading and i use
the mini stories to get up to a certain
level or you can actually take advantage
of a tutor but once you're at the level
i'm at now i can actually have a
conversation with my tutor and so
i make sure that i have two
conversations a week in arabic and two
conversations a week in persian
and the advantage there is that i'm sort
of committed to being with the tutor so
again that kind of propels me forward i
gotta do it i'm there uh i don't necess
i don't prepare in fact i shouldn't say
i don't prepare at all for my for my
interactions with my tutors they're both
excellent tutors they keep me going they
ask me questions they'll ask me about
the serial i'm watching in the case of
the egyptian arabic and i know sahara is
a great
tutor in terms of keeping me going and
once she's going to recommend a series
on on youtube
and we will be talking about that so i
just have to show up but i have to show
up so i'm committed twice a week now
that's my plan to show up in each of
those languages if i were doing i could
do one week of one language and one week
of the other and then similarly i would
have a commitment to show up but i've
decided to try to squeeze them into the
same week i don't know how it will all
go and i think that my final bit of
advice is
experiment with it i think some people
will find it more enjoyable to do two
languages at the same time than other
people some people may not enjoy doing
that some people may prefer to stay with
one language there is no
right way or wrong way or obligation do
the things that you find enjoyable stay
with the language stay with the process
and you will improve and so that's what
i have to say on learning two languages
at the same time thank you for listening